Mit dem Pufo in die Spaßgalaxie, nein, so weit weg war ich noch nie. Unterwegs gibt's Fun und jede Menge Witze, Florentin Will und Stefan, Daniel 3. Daniel 3. Wir haben mittlerweile schon so viele Intros gehabt, dass das der dritte Daniel ist. Kann man das mal hochrechnen? Ja, können wir mal einen Graphen machen vor allem, irgendwie diesem Subreddit Data is Beautiful, den ich ja sehr zu empfehlen habe. Und zwar die Relation, Nachname und Zugewandtheit dazu, ein Intro an einen Podcast zu schicken. Stimmt, ich glaube schon langsam haben wir eine repräsentative Stichprobe, wir haben genug Leute. Ich glaube, Daniel ist sehr weit oben. Vielen, vielen Dank Daniel, auf jeden Fall unter den Top 3 der Daniels. Tolles Intro, sehr schön, ich mag es, dass es jetzt mehr so in die Richtung persönlich geht. Wir haben so verschiedene Musikphasen, machen wir ja auch durch. Ja, wir machen das auch durch, also wir haben schon ein bisschen die Romantik durch, wir haben schon mit Podcast UFO Galaxy, Neue Spaß Galaxy. Wir hatten eine sehr lange Elektrophase, wo einfach nur Straight Beats einfach vierze Sekunden lang. Und jetzt finde ich es gut, dass wir uns so ein bisschen in die Kinderzimmer und Schlafzimmer. In die Singer-Songwriter-Ecke entwickelt haben. Genau, ja, wirklich so zu Hause ein junger Mann und seine Gitarre erobern die Welt. Ich finde es ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz toll. Auf jeden Fall. Ja, also fantastisches Intro hier von Daniel. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank, Daniel Florentin. Ich habe mich sehr gefreut, heute dich zu sehen.
Ja?
Ja, wirklich, weil ich ehrlich gesagt in dieser ganzen Zeit, wo man sehr viel Zeit zu Hause verbringt und so, ja auch schön Sonne ist und so man sich in den Garten setzt, toll, tolles Wetter hat.
Ich vermisse dich. Ich finde es schön, einen Tag in der Woche mit dir zu sprechen.
Das freut mich. Ja doch, es ist tatsächlich so, ich habe meine sozialen Kontakte auch stark reduziert. Ja, weil man endlich die Welt an einem die Hand ausgestreckt und man kann sie ergreifen und sagen, Leute, fickt euch alle, ich will euch nicht mehr sehen, oder? Ja, genau. Genau so ist es. Tatsächlich habe ich ein intensives Verhältnis angefangen mit meinen Nachbarn. Ich kann nämlich über den Hof schauen, zu anderen in die Wohnung. Und ich warte eigentlich nur, dass ich irgendwie so ein Verbrechen sehe oder so. Weil ich bin tatsächlich so ein bisschen wieder zu einem Fensterhelden geworden. Hast du schon so ein Kissen auf die Fensterbank gelegt, das ist die Frage. Ne, das noch nicht. Aber seitdem ich diese eine Chance verpasst habe, wo ich gesagt habe, ich habe im Hof beobachtet, wie zwei zwielige Gestalten ihre Nummernschilder ausgetauscht haben, wo
tatsächlich eine Polizistin mir auf Instagram
geschrieben hat, da hättest du mal die Polizei
rufen sollen. Seitdem habe ich ein schlechtes Gewicht.
Hast du die Hörer links
neben dem Liegen mit der Kurzweiltaste,
also weil 1-1-0 ist hier nicht kurz genug.
Wenn du das programmiert hast, dass du lange auf die 1 drücken musst,
dann kommt 1-1-0. Ich habe immer schon 1-1 gewählt,
mit dem Daumen schon auf der 0. Warum nicht die 0 schon?
Nee, ich muss nur noch loslassen. Ich muss nur noch loslassen und schon ist es Streifen rein. Du musst auf grün noch drücken werden, ist ja schon klar. Weiß ich gar nicht, muss man auf grün. Aber ich glaube, wenn man eine Telefonnummer eingibt und dann lange nichts macht, ruft der automatisch an. Das ist in den Filmen immer so geil, alle Filme, die sich irgendwie mit Voyeurismus auseinandersetzen und beginnen ja so, dass Leute aus irgendwelchen Gründen an ihr Haus gebunden sind, Fussfessel, Bein gebrochen, was auch immer, sitzen dann in der Wohnung und dann geht der Blick so rüber in Richtung Fernglas. Dann wird die Hand ausgestreckt und naja, kommt, hat man mein Fels in der Hand und man legt los und beobachtet grauenvolle Dinge oder tolle Dinge. Das einzige, was mich davon trennt, meine Nachbarn anzugucken, ist, dass ich kein Fernglas habe. Und Scheiss, weil hätte ich ein Fernglas? Leute, ich sehe nämlich jetzt mittlerweile, ich habe viele Fenster, ich sehe, was draußen passiert. Ich bin aber auch kurzsichtig und ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht genau, was davor sich geht. Ich würde gerne mehr sehen, mein Fernglas habe ich nicht. Ich glaube auch, dass, falls du ein bisschen Geld übrig hast zum Anlegen, ich glaube, dass jetzt Fernglasfirmen richtig durch die Decke gehen. Also ich glaube, da knorkt ein Sektkorken nach dem anderen, knallt da in den Innenräumen und alle schauen nur neidisch ins Chefdruck. Also diese alte Weisheit aber, dass Leute, die Taschentücher herstellen, es nur für Masturbation und unnütze Tränen machen, so machen Fernglashersteller, wollen wahrscheinlich eher, dass sie die Fernglasherstellen für Vögel beobachten. Das stimmt, nein. Ja, das ist auch so, oh Herr Tempo, Herr Tempo, kann ich kurz mit Ihnen reden, ich bin Riesenfan von Ihren Taschentüchern. Was machen Sie mit den Taschentüchern? Also wirklich, ich... Machen Sie, wenn Sie Kunstwerke malen, wischen Sie das dann weg, die übergebliebene Farbe, können wir Ihre Wohnung sauber halten? Ich komme jeden Tag von der Arbeit nach Hause und denke mir so, jetzt gehst du erst mal schön auf Pornhub und wichst dir ordentlich schön eine runter. Alles klar, dann wird so eine Falltür betätigt und fliegst du runter zu den anderen Masturbanten. Ja, und jedes Mal und tatsächlich, ich möchte Ihnen den Preis verleihen von der Masturbationsliga, den Preis für Tempotaschentücher, die besten Taschentücher, dass man da schön seine Ladung reingewenzt. Okay, ich stelle ihn kurz zum Sinnlose Tränen-Pokal. Was sind für dich sinnlose Tränen? Das klingt wie so ein ganz verträumtes Album. Ich meine, das ist ein Family Guy oder so. Aber diese Nonsens-Tränen. Aber könnte es nicht ein Song von Daniel sein? Sinnlose Tränen? Ja, Daniel, hau mal noch mal einen Hit raus. Hau da noch mal einen raus, bitte. Wir haben noch nicht genug von Daniel. Sinnlose Tränen. Ich hab für dich geweint, literweise, doch später stellt sich raus, ich krieg kein Pfand zurück, kein Pfand für die Liebe. Oh, das sind sinnlose Tränen, Podcast UFO, wir schreiben unser eigenes Intro. Ja, also das sind schon mal Songs, sinnlose Tränen und kein kein Fun für die Liebe, kriegst du schon mal direkt einfach so. Kein Fun für die Liebe. Aber unterscheidest du zwischen sinnlosen und sinnvollen Tränen? Also wenn du weinst... Sind nicht alle Tränen überflüssig zumindest, der Name. Oh, naja. Ich würde eher in die andere Richtung gehen, wenn ich dich kurz korrigieren darf. Sind nicht alle Tränen nützlich? Hä? Also kann man nicht aus jeder traurigen Erfahrung was mitnehmen? Ich habe keine starke Meinung zu Tränen. Ich finde, Tränen sollen machen, was sie wollen. Ich glaube nicht, dass Tränen jemandem Arbeitsplätze wegnehmen oder sonst. Ich finde, Tränen haben ihre Daseinsberechtigung. Bei dir im Gehirn läuft ein keines Gedankenmännchen den Meinungskorridor herunter, ausser Atem. Meinungen! Wir brauchen meinen!, okay, ich renne los, ich renne los, die EF bei T angekommen. Es schlägt Bücher auf und bellt sie durch, dieses Buch liefert keine Antworten, Tiere, Tiramisu, Tränen, riesige Aktenorten, leer, völlig leer, komplett leer, nur ein Taschentuch, ein gebrauchtes Taschentuch liegt da drin. Und so ein anderes Meinungsmännchen, was sagt, oh, Entschuldigung, ich dachte, da kommt niemand rein. Die Mittagsschicht, Mittagsschicht! Ha, ich, wie gesagt, freue mich sehr heute mit dir. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich so, ich bin auf einen guten Tag heute, hat man manchmal. Ja, weil es so warm ist und so sommerlich dahinschmelzend ist. Gestern habe ich... Es schmilzig. Ich habe jetzt überlegt, jeden Tag mindestens 10.000 Schritte zu gehen. Schaffe ich nicht. Aber ist mein Ziel? Einfach sehr viel gehen. Ich glaube, die beste Form, Leute, die die ganze Zeit Sport machen oder joggen und so, lasst euch mal gesagt, dass Gehen viel besser ist für euch. Weil beim Gehen denkt der Körper nicht, oh, hier wird gerade so viel verbraucht. Ich spare mir lieber noch die eine oder andere Kalorie, weil wenn das so weitergeht, dann sterben wir in drei Minuten. Und deswegen beim Gehen ist das die perfekte Anstrengung für den Körper zum Abnehmen. Angenommen, es gäbe für deinen Körper so eine Schaltung. Ich dachte, die meinte eine Gebrauchsanweise. Nee, ich meine, momentan läuft dein Körper auf Automatik. So, Aber wenn du die Möglichkeit hättest, auf manuell umzuschalten, sprich, du musst manuell atmen, du kannst aber auch bestimmen, wie dein Körper so mit Fett umgeht, weil du hast jetzt gerade deinen Körper beschrieben, als wäre es ein anderes Wesen. Ich habe quasi ein Spiel gestartet, so ein Rollenspiel, und ich habe die Steuerung noch auf einfach gestellt.
Genau.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es bei dir ist, viele haben das schon abgestellt, aber ich hab immer noch das Tutorial am Laufen. Bei mir steht bei Leuten immer noch ansprechen, nee, Nina will ich die noch nicht ansprechen, geh lieber jetzt woanders hin. Und wenn ich noch ein bisschen vorsichtig wirke vielleicht, dann liegt es auch daran, weil ich auch im unteren Rechten habe ich noch den Kompass an, und ich hab diese Taste für die Map ausschalten nicht gefunden. Das heißt, ich hab immer noch so halbtransparent so eine große Karte für eine Spielwelt vor meinem Auge. Ich hab auch immer noch so diese Tutorial-Texts, die ich noch nicht weggeklickt hab. Ich weiß nicht, ich find nicht das X. 15 aufeinander gestapelt und ich denk mir, ach komm, das wird zu blöd, die klicke ich nicht weg. Aber würdest du den Schalter umstellen? Also dann müsstest du auch aktiv so verdauen und so, das musst du alles manuell machen und halt so Zellteilung und so, da musst du dich um alles kümmern. Dann kannst du aber auch sagen. Krebs nach zwei Sekunden, weil ich habe vergessen, dass Zellen sich teilen, dann mutiert eine Zelle und dann so. Du schweifst ab. Je einfacher Organismen sind, desto weniger Fehler begehen die, oder? Ja, ich glaube so Einzeller, selten Krebs. Wirklich, die machen, also, überleg mal, wie viel die teilen.
Bei mir ist es wirklich so, ich teile was, also wenn du sagst, das ist ein Stapel mit Bällen, rote nach links, blaue nach rechts.
Das ging, glaube ich, so drei Minuten lang gut und dann schweife ich gedanklich ab und dann falsch, falsch, links, falsch, alle in Müll, alle fallen runter.
Da kommen grüne Bälle her, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das passiert häufig.
Nee, ich bin froh, dass ich das jetzt automatisch mache, wie atmen und so. Und selbst das vergesse ich oft genug, im Schlaf zum Beispiel. Ich bin ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,, also da kommen so Forscher den Meinungskorridor entlang gelaufen, mit so einem Pamphlet in der Hand, wo draufsteht, better Lord, better ladies. Gähnen ist auch dafür da, um das Gehirn zu kühlen. Stell dir mal vor, du bist in der Forschergruppe zum Thema Gähnen, und Gähnen steckt ja an, nur wenn man vom Gähnen redet. Irgendwann sagen die, wir müssen die Forschen abbrechen, weil wir sind alle so müde. Ja, deswegen kommt man ja und sagt ja nicht mehr zu Ergebnissen, was das Stichwort Gähnen angeht, weil die ganze Zeit auch, lass uns mal kurz hin, wobei, lass uns Feierabend machen, wir haben heuer, wir haben früh genug gemacht, wir haben auch früh angefangen schon.
Die Sauerstoffkonzentration im Blut ist ja beim Gön.
Vor allem, ehrlich gesagt, man kommt doch zu nichts.
Ich behaupte, man kommt doch zu nichts.
Ich behaupte, alle Menschen kommen zu nichts, weil sie zu clever sind. Also ich komme morgen ins Büro, dann ist erstmal Smalltalk angesagt, was vor allem der unnötig ist, weil man hat die Kollegen zuletzt gestern Abend gesehen. Naja, man kommt mal morgens rein, sagt, was hast du so erlebt, jeder hat eben eine kleine Geschichte, dann setzt man sich hin, fängt mal an.
Dann hat man das erste kleine IT-Problem. letzt, gestern Abend gesehen, naja, man kommt mir morgens rein, sagt, was hast du erlebt, jeder hat eben eine kleine Geschichte,
dann setzt man sich hin, fängt mal an.
Dann hat man das erste kleine IT-Problem wahrscheinlich schon mal. Internet
geht nicht, Laptop ist leer,
Ladekabel vergessen, kleine Problemchen,
die so gut und gerne eine 10 Minuten
einnehmen können. Dann wieder ein bisschen
Smalltalk, dann auch erst mal ankommen,
erst mal Reddit checken,
Facebook, Instagram checken, dann aufstehen, stöhnen, als hätte man schon was gemacht, geht in die Küche, holt sich einen Kaffee, holt sich das Käffchen, ah, willst du auch was, hab dich vergessen, gar nicht gesehen, komm noch, geh nochmal raus, holt einen Kaffee. Oh, kannst du mir vielleicht auch einen Kaffee mitbringen, ich geh nochmal zurück. Nee, ich mach schon, ich geh mit Milch, ah, hab ich vergessen, hol. Hol die Milch mit Zucker. Nein, okay, kennt man sich ja schon. Der Herr Krukowski. Ja, hallo. Dann der erste Anruf oder der erste Gast. So, dann redet man wieder ein bisschen Smalltalk. Dann ist es auch schon fast zwölf und es geht in Weil, man weiss ja auch, Lieferando dauert eine Stunde, bis die kommen. Man beschäftigt sich jetzt schon ein bisschen eher mit dem Mittagessen-Phänomen. So, dann viel Diskussion. Was essen wir denn heute? Ne, Sushi, ne, was auch. Während das Essen unterwegs ist, kann eh niemand arbeiten, weil sich alle aus Essen freuen. Das heißt, man klappt da erstmal schon mal die Laptop zu. Mittagspause beginnt ja mit dem Absenden der Bestellung, klar. So, dann kommt das Essen, vielleicht ein bisschen zu spät, dann ist schon so 14 Uhr und dann ist ja, sagen wir mal, erstmal so eine Postlunchlethargie, setzt ja ein, viel Gän, viel, oh, das war jetzt zu viel, oh, jetzt muss ich mir erstmal kurz ein bisschen ausdenken. Die Packungen stehen noch auf dem Tisch, wer räumt das weg? Ach, aber wir haben auch schon viel geschafft heute so. Ja. Kommen wir mal entspannt. Also ich würde sagen, den Termin, den 18 Uhr Termin legen wir auf morgen. Nee, das lohnt sich jetzt nicht mehr, das machen wir morgen. Das lohnt sich nicht mehr, den machen wir morgen. Gut, was haben wir denn noch zu tun? Alles klar. Und dann geht es so in Richtung Nachmittag, um 16 Uhr denkt man, jetzt was Neues anzufangen, macht auch keinen Sinn mehr. Dann lässt man den Tag so ausplätschern und dann geht man von morgen, sieht es von neuem los. Und dann ist Donnerstag ja Feiertag, eh. Und dann irgendwann wirst du befördert und bist der Chef und musst dich darum kümmern, dass die Leute ihre Arbeit machen, bist aber so in diesem Prokrastinieren drin, dass du das einfach nicht machst. Und irgendwann kommt einfach Mr. Jakamoto und sagt, sie haben in den letzten 15 Jahren nichts erwirtschaftet, null, also gar nichts. Ja, weil wir hatten dann noch das Problem, dass der Papierkorb voll war. Beschreiben Sie mir, was Ihre Firma macht. Naja, wir hatten erst überlegt, ob wir den blauen oder den gelben Basketballkorb für den Papiereimer holen sollen. Und dann konnten wir uns nicht einigen, weil Ulf im Urlaub ist und dann musste der zurückkommen. Ja, genau, und deswegen ist meine große Theorie, weil dann ist ja oft Donstags noch feiertag freitags kasse brückentag montags macht man eh nie was mittwoch geht schon steiler wochenende zu und dienstag ist man noch geschafft vom ansteigenden montag ich behaupte der mensch schafft nichts null wir leben total unter unseren fähigkeiten und es ist auch in allen belangen so das ja auch die Journalisten und das machen auch die Virologen.
Oh, weiss ich nicht.
Sorry.
Ich werde immer sofort rot, wenn ich Satire gemacht habe.
Satirealarm.
Ich werde immer sofort, weiss ich nicht.
War das jetzt richtig?
Trifft es den Richtigen?
Man weiss es nicht.
Nein.
Ja, aber das Lustige war, meine Mutter ist Personalerin, HR, von so einem schönen Unternehmen, so 300 Mitarbeiter, 400 Mitarbeiter, und die hat erzählt, dass es jetzt ein Fall aufkam, dass sie jemanden kündigen mussten, weil aufgefallen ist, dass der seit vier Jahren nichts macht. Und es ist so peu à peu aufgeploppt, weil erst kamen so ein paar Beschwerden rein, so den braucht niemand und das kommt halt ab und zu mal so Beschwerden, anonyme Beschwerden. Dann wurden so ein bisschen umstrukturiert und es wurden neue Stellen ausgeschrieben und durch die Umstrukturierung wurden auch ein paar Bereiche von ihm übernommen und so. Dann kam noch eine Beschwerde rein und dann wurde die Stelle immer besetzt und dann kam raus, Moment mal, aber wenn der jetzt diese neue Stelle jetzt das übernimmt von ihm, seinem Bereich und diese andere Stelle jetzt das übernimmt von seinem Bereich und dann die Beschwerden rauskommen, sollten wir den mal fragen, was er denn eigentlich gemacht hat die letzten drei Jahre? Kam raus, nichts. Und es kommt wohl häufiger vor. Für mich war das fantastisch. Ja, absolut. Das ist der Wahnsinn. Dieses Gespräch. Was machen Sie eigentlich? Habe ich auch was, was sind Sauer auf diesen Menschen? Weil er hat doch eigentlich alles richtig gemacht. Darum geht es doch. Menschen wollen doch diesen Zustand des Nichtstun perfektionieren, kriegt er auch noch Geld dafür und eigentlich gebührt ihm doch eine Art Preis, finde ich. Ja, und dann kam raus, dass er nichts gemacht hat und dann haben wir ihn konfrontiert und er hat gesagt, ja, okay, dann rufen wir jetzt eine neue Firma. Und dann werden wir jetzt eine neue Firma suchen und da genau den gleichen Job suchen. Perfekt, aber es gibt, obwohl häufiger, sogar Teileichen, das kommt ab und zu mal vor. So vom System Vergessen, vergessene Nichtstuer, die Gewinner dieser Gesellschaft. Absolut. Fantastisch. Aber ich fände es auch gut, wenn er sich selber irgendwann gemeldet hätte, so nach fünf Jahren so, ich mache seit fünf Jahren hier nichts. Mir ist ein bisschen langweilig, ich will den Job jetzt kündigen. Also ganz irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, aber es stimmt schon. Aber war das immer so? Also war das auch früher im Mittelalter schon so, dass die Leute aufs Feld gegangen sind und dann erstmal so ein bisschen rumgestochert und dann so ein bisschen links, rechts und dann oh, ein Schatten und so. Ich glaube, die Unwendigkeit besteht nicht mehr, weil da war halt so ein bisschen so, ja, wenn wir jetzt nicht diese zwei Kartoffeln, die wir auf diesem Feld gut anbauen konnten, weil wir nicht wissen, wie man Kartoffeln anbaut, wenn wir die nicht ernten, dann ist es vorbei, dann können wir direkt einpacken. Zumal da hinten ja auch, siehst du da hinten, da auch kommen die Römer angelaufen. Wo kommen denn die, wo ist denn Rom? Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung. Scheiße. Wir hätten mal ein bisschen Überstunden gemacht in Geografie. Ja, und dann glaube ich, die Nullendlichkeit bestand einfach durch diesen harten Konkurrenzkampf,
Kriege. Kriege haben ja auch was Gutes.
Ja,
kommt drauf an.
Ja, für den Fortschritt.
Du meinst, dass du dann
irgendwie so eine ganz grosse Armbrust
baust? Ja, die grössere Armbrust.
Du baust die besseren Armbrust. Ganz grosse
Armbrust und dann deine Soldaten
auf den Gegner schießt, in die Burg hinein?
Ich sag mal so, wenn wir jetzt
Vielen Dank. baust. Ja, die grössere Armbrust. Du baust die besseren Armbrüste. Ganz grosse Armbrust und dann deine Soldaten auf den Gegner schießt, in die Burg hinein.
als Erde das Kämpfen perfektionieren
und immer bessere
Wettrüsten, immer bessere Waffen haben
und dann kommt mal die Alienrasse,
die hier nur gucken will, wie es hier so aussieht
und ein paar Blümchen pflücken will,
die können wir dann ganz einfach gewinnen, weil wir
die besseren Armbrüste haben. Ja, das stimmt. Die müssen wir halt nochmal rausholen irgendwo, jeder hat noch einen im Keller. Ja, aber, oder nicht, also verstehst du nicht, wenn man als, weil alle sagen immer, ja friedlich, Planet muss nach vorne gucken, ja ist eine blöde These, ehrlich gesagt, führt auch jetzt in die falsche Richtung. Ist ja die Frage, ob wir dann nicht irgendwie schon bald wissen, also irgendwann wissen wir so, in tausend Jahren kommen die Aliens. Weil wir haben die gesehen mit unserem Spektrometer. Ja, die kommen sehr lange auf uns zu. Und die sind super langsam. Aber würde das was für dein Leben jetzt verändern, wenn die in tausend Jahren kämen? Ey, das wäre die schlimmste Nachricht der Welt. Ja, traurig. Weil du denkst, ja, kann ich mich einfrieren lassen oder so? Schön zu Walt Disney in die Kühltruhe steigen oder so? Geht das noch? Ist da noch Platz in einer großen Bahne? Wie groß ist die denn und er sagt nee wo die wald disney corporation sagt nein hä wie auf storage oh tschuldigung wie auf auftauen gekommen ich war ein bisschen schwitzig jetzt bin ich war zu warm ich habe wald disney aufgetaut und dann legst du da erstmal in dem gefrierfach und dann so und wie ist die welt ach warten tausend jahren drüber lassen Lassen wir mal wieder einfrieren. Ich glaube, wenn die Aliens kommen, dann in so einem ganz langsamen intergalaktischen Ruderboot. Einfach so ganz langsam. Also komm, voran. Sollen wir euch entgegenkommen? Braucht ihr ein Seil? Passt schon. Passt schon, passt schon, passt schon. Wir leben fünfhunderttausend Jahre, wir aber nicht. Unser Metabolismus ist sehr langsam. Schöp euch! Wir haben Stress hier unten, bei uns ist immer was los und morgen ist auch Feiertag. Dann kommen die an, hallo, oh mein Gott. Und wir aufgepeilt durch Internet, News und die sind so die entspanntesten Lebewesen der Welt, die sind richtig langweilig die sind richtig langweilig ja so wirklich so das kürzeste Interesse aller Zeiten, alle so und was macht ihr so, ja also wir haben also wir gehen halt gern spazieren gut, wollt ihr noch lange bleiben oder ihr müsst doch wieder los wieder. Ja, wir haben euch was mitgebracht, das ist so ein, ja, das ist so ein Kuchen, so ein Früchtekuchen. Wenigstens mit euren Früchten oder so? Nee, Birne, Birnenkuchen, Birnenkuchen, ja, und wir also... Cool, was sind so eure Interessen? Naja, also Schmetterlinge mögen wir ganz gerne. Schmetterlinge? Wenigstens eure habt ihr irgendwie ... Nee, also wir haben eine ganze Sammlung und halt so Gespräche über was so passiert. Wollt ihr wenigstens uns irgendwie ... Wollt ihr Invasionen machen oder so? Wollt ihr uns umbringen? Nein, wir kommen ganz friedlich. Habe ich mir schon fast gedacht. Habt ihr? Also, wir können ja was spielen, Rummikub oder so, falls ihr Lust habt. Nee, ich muss jetzt auch los. Nee, ja, dann wir müssen auch los., wart ihr beliebt auf dem letzten Planeten, wo ihr wart, oder?
Ja, wir sind die Auserwählten, wir sind die spannendsten unserer Rasse.
Ja, ihr seid die spannendsten unserer Rasse?
Wir waren unseren Planeten vertreten.
Und wart ihr schon auf anderen Planeten, kamt ihr da gut an?
Ähm, na ja.
Haben die mit euch Rimmikop gespielt?
Na ja, einmal, aber dann, aber dann mussten die auch
los. Mussten los, ne?
Mussten von ihrem Planeten los.
Ja, die mussten dann weg. Komisch,
dass die von ihrem Planeten los mussten, rückblickend.
Ja.
Wir müssen auch alle los.
Ja, sieben
Milliarden Menschen müssen jetzt los.
Ja, aber war schön.
Tschüss. Ja, nett, oder? Und dann kommtst du raus, dass das Serienstrategie ist, um die gesiedliche Variante. Und dann bohren die nach Brom. Wir wollen Brom haben. Brom. Wir haben keinen Brom in unserem Planetensystem. Es ist ein Brom. Jeder hat so einen kleinen Löffel mitgebracht. Brom-Löffel. Ein Brom-Göffel. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Wo man auch machen kann und dann auch essen kann. Die Alien-Rasse genau wie Menschen, nur sie hat Göffel statt Löffel. Das ist der einzige Unterschied. Ja, auch so Sandalen irgendwie und so farbige Sonnenbrillen. Aber halt Göffel, das ist so der einzige Unterschied. Und auch so so coolige Kugelschreiber in der Hemdstasche oben. Das hände ich auch so lustig. So Hawaii-Hemden. Hawaii-Hemden mit so einem Kugelschreiber. Warst du dabei, SpaceX? Bist du aktiv? Warst du beim Launch dabei, 3, 2, 1, go? Ich hab's verfolgt, dann wurde der Start abgesagt. Ja, ich war auch live dabei tatsächlich. Ich hab auf Twitter gesehen, so T-minus eine Minute und bei T-minus bin ich dabei. Bei T-minus bist du sofort dabei. Bist du sofort dabei. Und dann, ja, nee, wurde abgebrochen wegen schlechtem Wetter. Ja, wo ich auch sage, wenn schlechtes Wetter für diese Rakete eine Gefahr ist, dann lass es. Wenn für uns als Menschheit ein Wölkchen gefährlich wird, dann mache ich mir mir ein bisschen Gedanken. Wir brauchen die Mütze, holt die Mütze! Und dann kriegt die Rakete so eine grosse Mütze. So eine Regenjacke an. Der Anorak, wir brauchen den Anorak. Anorak-Kran. Schal, nicht das Sporttrikot. Anorak! Und dann den Schal so dreimal. Rotation one. Rotation two, go. R minus fünf. Das ist ein Loopschal, einfach so eingewickelt. So, jetzt geht's los. So, jetzt geht's los. Aber sei vorsichtig. Es klärt auf, der Himmel klärt auf. Anorak abziehen, aber sei vorsichtig. Hängt top an. Pass auf dich auf in fünf, vier und dann geht's los. Dann geht's los und ich finde, ja, und man war halt abgesagt und dann war ich nicht mehr so am Start. Nee, das war dann irgendwie. Der Drive war raus. Ich glaube, auch für die Astronauten.
Total.
Ich habe immer eine Meinung geändert.
Ich glaube, die Astronauten an meinem zweiten Mann nicht mehr so richtig Bock.
Vor allem stell dir vor, du packst dein ganzes Zeug,
denkst, du fliegst jetzt in den Weltraum und kommst dann in deinem Apartment wieder an.
Ja. Irgendwie alles noch aufgeräumt.
Deine Frau hat schon neun.
Äh, Frau so, ach Schatz, da bist du ja wieder.
Oh. Oh.
Ich habe noch gar nicht mit dir gerechnet. Ach so. Wessen das? Hm? Wer das ist? Wer der Mann ist? Das ist Hugo. Hugo, so so. Hugo aus der IT bei dir. Ja, du hast ja gesagt, du bist jetzt für sieben, siebzehn Jahre weg. Ja. Also für uns auf der Erde sind es ja hundertsechzig Jahre. Ich glaube nicht, das ist so ein Weg.
Also ich habe Interstellar gesehen.
Ich fliege zu ISS, das ist auch nicht die Ewigkeit.
Hä, ich habe Interstellar, da hieß es doch, dass das andere Zeit ist.
Ja, das ist ein Film, ich fliege gleich zwei Tage, in zwei Stunden bin ich da oben.
Ach so.
Aber ich bin Astronaut, Scheitz, ich bin Astronaut.
Bist du nicht stolz? Naja, früher war das halt schon was, aber mittlerweile, ich meine, du sitzt vor dem Touchpad und drückst da drauf, go. Das stimmt. Nee, ich sage nur noch, Rakete start, start. Im Grunde sagen die im Kontrollraum start und du guckst aufs Touchpad. Aber ich muss kontrollieren, ob die ganzen Anzeigen stimmen. Naja, aber das machen die auch vom Kontrollraum. Du könntest ja gar nichts ändern.
Aber wenn der Funk abbricht, dann musst du dich einschreiben. Vor allem, es war wirklich so ein Flashback, weil wir haben ja bei guter Arbeit diesen Sketch gemacht, wo sie auf dem Mars fliegen, zu dritt und nur zwei kommen zurück. Und in diesem SpaceX-Shuttle waren drei Sitze, aber es waren nur zwei Leute drin gesessen. Ein Sitz war leer. Weil er sich niemals getraut hat, bei Houston so ...
Wo ist Joe?
Wo ist Hubi eigentlich? Oder sie sollen einen mitnehmen von der ISS und der weiß es noch nicht. Warum? Aber die nehmen einen mit, ja. Wie einen mitnehmen? Nee, fliegen die zurück? Ja doch, Soyuz Caps, nee, sag ich nicht Soyuz Caps, das ist eben nicht Stefan Hirn. Wie, die fliegen nicht zurück? Hm. Das ist dieser klassische, du hast acht Wikipedia-Artikel zu dem Thema gelesen und weißt jetzt gar nichts mehr, Blick, den ich kenne, den ich kenne, von mir, aber auch von dir. Klar, nee, die fliegen zurück, natürlich fliegen die zurück. Wann? Die Kapsel jetzt. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Ja, grob. Eine Woche oder einem Jahr oder? Irgendwas zwischen zwei Tagen und acht Jahren. Vor allem wird die ja auch auseinandergebaut, das wird die ISS. Die wird aufgegeben. Und meine Frage ist, warum? Das war's, oder was? Weiter geht's. Das ist deine Frage. deine frage warum das ist ein richtiger ist ein richtiger brummer diese frage also das ist eine harte nutz wird jetzt wie abgebaut also baut man wieder so schäbig ein wie so ein lego karton den du halt für eine sache aufbauen kann es ist halt wie bei so einer cornflakes packung du knaust da oben die tüte zusammen, aber es ist nicht wie neu. Halt so, ja,
du wirst die Packung offen, die
Plastiktüte wird so ein bisschen eingerollt,
aber das ist nicht wie neu.
Glaubst du, man kann das Knautschen,
ich weiß gar nicht, was du meinst, auch bei Brot,
Bäcker haben das ja perfektioniert,
Bäcker knautchen die Tüte oben so zusammen
immer. Lernt man das eigentlich bei der
Bäcker-Ausbildung, das Knautschen?
Ich glaube schon.
Ja, vor allem, ich glaube, die schauen sehr herab auf die Leute, die diese Plastikklammer haben. Also ne, richtig schön. Wobei ich hätte schon gerne diese Klammer. Du musst es besser wissen. Knautschen ist schön, ich glaube, das lernt man dann auch da. Ich glaube, das hilft auch, was aktiv macht. Ja, ich glaube, das hilft auf jeden Fall. Was gar nichts hilft, ist die Papierpackung oben zuzumachen. Das war echt so ein ... Es gibt ja zwei Leute, die die Plastiktüte rollen, aber oben nicht zumachen, die Papierpackung, und Leute, die die Papierpackung zumachen, aber das Plastikding nicht knautchen, wo man sich denkt, wo lebt ihr denn, als ob das irgendwas bringen will.
Hast du sowas wie frischhaltige Klammern bei dir in der Wohnung?
Hast du einen Brotkasten bei dir in der Wohnung?
Tue ich nicht.
Wie muss man deine Küche, ich habe jetzt eine neue Küche übrigens, endlich habe ich eine Küche.
Ja, du musst nicht mehr alles auf dem Grill machen, du musst nicht mehr morgens deine Cornflakes auf dem Grill warm machen.
Ich habe meine Tresor Kellogg's, wie es sich gehört, auf dem Grill morgens warm gemacht. Nee, wie muss man dir deine Küche vorstellen? Ich glaube, dir fehlt alles. Mir fehlt alles, mir fehlt vor allem Messbecher. Ich hatte einen Messbecher, ich war bei Ikea und es gab zwei Messbecher, den aus Glas und den aus Plastik. Und ich dachte mir, na jetzt pass mal auf, der alte Florentin hätte den aus Plastik gekauft.
Aber du bist erwachsen. Na der fällt mir runter und dann geht er kaputt, aber er sieht halt scheiße aus. Nein, der neue Florentin kauft sich einen Glasmessbecher, aber der neue Florentin kann auf sich aufpassen. Zwei Sekunden nachdem wir den benutzt haben. Mit dem Hotdog in der Hand auf dem Weg zum Parkplatz fällt mir der Messbecher runter. Und tatsächlich ist mir der Messbecher kaputt gegangen und seitdem habe ich ein ausgeklügeltes Flaschensystem, mit dem ich wie bei diesem Rätsel, dieses du hast fünf Liter, drei Liter, ein Liter und musst es dann so umschütten, dass es vier Liter sind oder irgendwie sowas. Und genau so mache ich es auch. Ich habe eine 0,5 Flasche, ich habe eine 0,3 Flasche und ich habe noch so ein Schnapsgläschen mit, glaube ich, zwei Zentiliter oder sowas. Und da schütte ich dann immer um, wenn im Rezept steht irgendwie 400 Milliliter, dann muss ich hin und her schütten, bis ich die richtige, es ist immer wie ein kleines Rätsel. Einfach weil ich meinen scheiß Messbecher zerstört habe, muss ich jetzt immer so umschütten. Deswegen steht bei mir in der Küche immer so ein ganzes, so eine ganze Palette an alten Flaschen, mit denen ich rumschütten muss. Und es ist lächerlich. Moment, du hast 500 Milliliter? Ja. 800 Milliliter? Ne, 800 gibt es nicht, 700. Ne, achthundert gibt's nicht, siebenhundert.
Siebenhundert, aber so viel braucht man selten.
So, wenn du auf zweihundert kommen willst,
machst du entweder
zwanzig, zwei Zentiliter,
ne, zehn,
ne, du machst die
zehn Pinnchen oder
ne, du machst die 0,7 voll,
du machst die 0,7 voll und schüttest einen halben ab.
Ja, aber du willst ja nicht tief, ja, ja.
Und dann hast du 200 übrig im 0,7. Ja, du kannst aber auch die, ja, du kannst die 700er voll machen. Genau. Oder du kannst, und dann kannst du die in die 500er reinmachen und dann wuchst du da rüberbleibt. Ja, genau. Ja, aber dann hast du ja, dann ist die halt voll mit Olivenöl. Wer? Die andere Flasche. Ja, dann tue ich sie wieder zurück. Aber was für ein Gericht ist das mit 200 Milliliter Olivenölbos? Oh ja, okay, machst du das zurück. Ja, es ist anspruchsvoll, es ist nicht leicht. Ich mache es mir nicht leicht. Nee, aber du hast ja die Zeit. Ich bedenke mich jetzt, wie kriegst du das rum, die Zeit, die viel, die viel Zeit. Und ehrlich gesagt, wahrscheinlich durch sowas, du machst dein Leben auf eine coole Art spannend. Ja, spannend. Oder ich habe manchmal einfach 100 Milliliter Olivenöl zu viel in meinem Thunfischsalat. Und dadurch habe ich ein Problem, auch ein massives Cholesterinproblem tatsächlich. Ja, gut. Und dann bin ich beim Arzt und er sagt, warum essen Sie so viel Fett? Ja, wissen Sie, der alte Florentin wäre jetzt gesund, aber der neue Florentin nicht, der hat seinen Messbecher zerstört. Der hat einen Glas-Glas-Messbecher. Sie bestehen, meinerseits besteht der menschliche Körper ja zu 70, 80 % aus Wasser, sie bestehen tatsächlich zu 70 % aus Olivenöl. Extra Vergine. Ich weiß mal nicht, was das heißt. E bestehen aus italienischem, nativen Olivenöl. Ich habe auch in mein Testament geschrieben, ich möchte, wenn ich tot bin, möchte ich Dressing sein. Dann will ich schön, dass meine Beerdigung eine riesige Salatschüssel aufgebaut wird und ich oben, wie über so einen Grapefruit ausdrücke, Auspresser, ich will einmal ausgepresst werden, als Dressing und alle müssen von diesem Salat essen.
Sie wollen oder nicht.
Jeder kriegt einen Teller und muss davon essen.
Weil einfach, ich will nicht, dass ich dieses ganze Extra-Vergine-Öl ins Grab mitnehme.
Das war teuer, das war gut. Vergine. Ja, Vergine. Vergine. Naja, so. Du hast wie ich das Problem, dass du das eine Wort, was du kennst, in der Sprache zu gut aussprichst, das dann in dem Land sagst, alle denken, du sprichst fließend Italienisch und du aus dem Teufelskreis nicht mehr rauskommst. Entschuldigung, ich suche einen Parmigiano. Ja, der ist hier geboren. Ciao, ciao. No comprendo, Parmigiano, no comprendo. Ja, aber ansonsten läuft es gut. Alles, was ich habe, habe ich tatsächlich von meinem Vormieter übernommen. Das heißt heißt das, was man normalerweise zurücklässt, wenn man auszieht, ist alles das, was ich habe. Also stell dir vor, jemand hat so beim Umzug alles, was unten im Umzugskarton übrig bleibt, was man nicht hinstellt, weil es so Kram, Krusch ist, das ist alles, was du hast, um zu leben, den Müll von anderen. Und du hast dann halt so irgendwie noch so ein paar asiatische Essstäbchen, du hast so ein paar Sojasoßenpackungen, davon lebe ich. Viele Geschenke, die nicht du bekommen hast, sondern der Vormieter, die er nicht mitnehmen wollte. Genau. So eine Glasflasche voller Farbe, weiß ja auch nicht genau, was das ist. Du hast doch eine Flasche. Aber ich kann dir gerne mal die Sachen, die jetzt bei mir übrig geblieben sind im Umzug machen. Ich will nicht deinen Krams. Du hast so wenigstens... Dein Krusch. Du hast so wenigstens mal ein bisschen Abwechslung in deinem Krusch. Ja. Wenn Krusch dein Leben ist, ist mehr Krusch doch ein besseres Leben. Ja, das stimmt schon. Das stimmt schon. Letztens habe ich mir ein Feuerzeug gekauft, bin ja extra, jetzt war ich, ich habe nie geraucht.
Aber jetzt fängst du an. Jetzt habe ich schon das Feuerzeug. Das war tatsächlich so ein Punkt, wo man dann mal so eine Kerze anmachen wollte zum Baden, aber ich habe einfach kein Feuerzeug gefunden und dachte mir, wie mache ich Feuer? Lege ich jetzt so ein Blatt Zeitung auf ein Herdblatt oder was, facke einfach meine ganze Welt. Das habe ich schon mal gemacht. mal gemacht. Das habe ich mir nicht getraut, weil ich vor allem kann es mir nicht leisten, dass meine Wohnung abbrennt.
Das geht nicht.
Die Schlagzeile wäre zu köstlich.
Und der ganze Krusch.
Wohin mit dem ganzen Krusch?
Es ist, ich habe viel zu viel übrig.
Aber na ja, ansonsten, was man halt so macht, ich beobachte die Nachbarn auf der Suche nach Verbrechen.
Und ich habe jedem Auge. Und du hast jetzt ein Feuerzeug gefunden? Ich habe ein Feuerzeug gefunden, rot. Also gekauft, auch ein unübliches. Ich habe mich tatsächlich sehr cool gefühlt. Bist du in einem Kiosk gewesen? Schön, nee, kein Kiosk, schön im Supermarkt, einfach noch mit an der Kasse drauf. Und ich habe es so leger gemacht, weil gerade wenn man so Sachen das erste Mal kauft, kennt man ja so irgendwie Deo oder Kondome oder so, dann versucht man es maximal leger zu machen, so, ach so, ja, so brauche ich noch. Und genau so habe ich auch dieses Feuerzeug gekauft, so, was gibt es hier? Ah, okay, er kauft zum ersten Mal. Ach so, Feuer für ein Plastikflaschchen, ja, ist doch okay, nehm ich, warum nicht? Ach, das ist ja günstig nehmen wir kommen ja mal oder wie viel habe ich noch zu hause zwei ja brauche ich mal eins ja ich habe ja schon 80 in meinem leben ja also auch die sehen ja ganz nett aus war so bunt ja ja
warum nicht nämlich so habs ja ja das ist ja kein Problem. So, wollen Sie jetzt die erste Verwerbung verkaufen in dem Leben oder nicht? Ja, nehm ich, kein Problem. Und die Kondom auch? Ja, verkauft man halt so, ist ja kein, ist ja kein Problem. Und das ist meine neueste Anschaffung, da bin ich sehr stolz drauf. Aber ich stand vor einem weirden Paradox und dann waren die Masken, die man kaufen konnte, standen an der Kasse, die Atemschutzmasken am Anfang von Corona. Man kam aber nur in den Supermarkt rein mit einer Atemschutzmaske. Ah ja. Klassisches, schwierig, Komplettlösung. Problem, ja, wo man dann mal nachgucken möchte. Komplettlösungs-Hotline anrufen, so. Entschuldigung. Was mache ich denn da? Was mache ich denn da? Das steht jetzt in dem Dungeon, ich brauche den Pfeil, den Bogen um den Dungeon zu tun. Sie müssen mit der Hand auf Kassierer klicken, auf Interagieren klicken. Ach so. So, und dann müssen sie das Geld da reinziehen, was sie vorher bei dieser Sidequest gesammelt haben. Da kommt immer eine Fehlermeldung. Ja, das ist ein Bug, einfach mal kurzes Spiel aktualisieren bitte. Achso, okay, gut, danke. Ich habe ja tatsächlich früher mal bei der Pokémon-Hotline angerufen, weil ich nicht weitergekommen bin. Es gab, bitte was? Es gab, es gab damals für jedes Spiel eine Hotline, es war vor Internetzeiten. Wer hat denn da gearbeitet? Ja, halt irgendwelche krassen, eben ist der beste Job der Welt? Es ist der beste Job der Welt, er hat, aber vor allem, man konnte sich auch so Komplettlösungen kaufen, das heißt, er hatte die halt. Und wahrscheinlich haben die Leute immer nur mit den gleichen drei Fragen angerufen. Die da wären? Wo in der Safari-Zone ist Surfer? Wo finde ich den Türöffner für Don Giovannis Hochhaus? Und wo ist auf MSN Surfer? So, das sind so die drei Fragen.
Auf wo?
Auf MSN, auf dem Kurzfahrtschiff.
Und wo, kannst du uns kurz alle drei Lösungen sagen?
Naja, also in der Safari-Zone musst du links oben, rechts oben, links unten und dann so mittig.
MSN musste einmal ganz nach rechts durch, der musste gegen deinen Rivalen kämpfen und dann kriegst du vom Kapitän den Schneider und den Türöffner kriegst du im Lavandia im Friedhof. Keine Weitere von Fragen. Ja, und dann habe ich angerufen und war verzweifelt und dann hat er mir geholfen und tatsächlich aber ein Freund von mir, der war super cool und der ist immer in immer in die Glitchstadt gekommen, da gibt es so eine Glitchstadt, wo alles verglitscht ist, halt so Fehler im Spiel oder so und da, und da wusste der, wie man da hinkommt und der war der Einzige in der Klasse, der wusste, wie man in diese Bug City kommt.
Aber es kommt immer ein, der besser weiß er. Ja, wo sind die aber jetzt?
Du, die sind jetzt reich, die sind jetzt irgendwo auf, die reiten auf einem weissen Ross durch die Wüste und werfen Geld um sich. Durch Glitchtowns. Die rennen so ganz schnell gegen eine Wand, auf ihrem Achtbit-Ding stehen sie in Wänden und man denkt, geil, du hast es geschafft. Die machen so einen Doppelsprung auf dem Pferd, wo man sagt, das geht doch gar nicht. Geht gar nicht, doch im Zirkus arbeiten die vielleicht. Ja, aber im Zirkus. Und damit kommen sie dann über die unsichtbare Mauer, dass sie eigentlich dahin gehen dürfen. Und er kam in diese Glitch City und er dachte dann so, hä, ich rufe jetzt bei der Hotline an und fragte ihn, wie man da wieder rauskommt. Das weiss der bestimmt nicht, weil nur ich weiss, wenn er in die Glitch City kommt. Und ruft er an und macht auf Lautsprecher für uns alle, damit wir hören, wie cool er ist, ruft an und er einfach mit dem Telefon, ja, dann müssen wir einfach das Spiel neu starten und gucken,
dass der Speicherstand nicht überschrieben ist. Wow. Und er hat gesagt, Papa, bist du das?
Robert? Papa, Sie verarbeitet bei der Pokemon-Hotline, was? Robert, du ... Ich denke, du bist Bäcker.
Du cloutschst die Tüten doch so schön. Was denn? What, what das ...? What, hier ist eine riesige ... Ah! Hier ist eine riesige Motte. Wo kam die denn her? Gott, die war die ganze Zeit da. Ich dachte, das wäre ein Riss in diesem Ding. Die saß die ganze Zeit da. Aber die war ... Wo ist sie denn jetzt hingegangen? Hinter dem Ding. Hier ist so ein Schallschutzding. Die saß die ganze Zeit da drauf, hier ist so ein Flecken. Hier war doch seit Wochen niemand mehr in dem Raum. Das stimmt. Wie kommt die, was für ein Leben haben diese Viecher? Ja, wo kommen die mal her? Ey, diese Scheiss-Mücken auch bei mir ständig in der Wohnung, jede wirkliche, ach Stefan, die tut dir nix. Hallo. Hallo. Ja, hallo. Das war's. Mehr kann ich nicht tun. Mehr kann ich nicht tun. Bei dir in der Wohnung sind auch Motten. Hast du ein Mottenproblem? Nee, Motten gar nicht, aber ich bin einfach ein Idiot und ich will immer noch mal lüften, bevor ich ins Bett gehe. Und jetzt habe ich mir überlegt, ich muss das Licht ausmachen, sonst kommen Mücken rein. Das heißt, ich sitze jetzt immer, bevor ich ins Bett gehe, fünf Minuten lang in Stille, in Dunkelheit in meiner Wohnung, damit es lüftet, bevor ich dann wieder was lesen kann, wenn ich ins Bett gehe, sitze ich dann da und mache gar nichts. Einfach nichts. Ja, manchmal spielt das Leben einen furchterlichen Trick. Und dann sitzt man da und denkt, das ist mein Leben, ich sitze in meiner Wohnung, es zieht und ich mache nichts. Ja, und ich warte, bis Luft sich bewegt. Warum, wo will die Luft hin? Was ist Luft, was ist Luft, so. Wie, also wie, ja genau, also ich weiß, wie man alte Luft zu neuer Luft macht, man lüftet, aber wie wird alte Luft zu neuer Luft da draußen? Wer reinigt die denn? Bäume.
Du kannst dir übrigens auch eine schöne Pflanze kaufen. Habe ich letztens darüber nachgedacht, eine Erdnusspflanze. Ich wollte eine Erdnusspflanze, weil du musst einfach nur Erdnüsse einpflanzen, dann wächst da was raus und dann hast du irgendwann neue Erdnüsse und das ist doch eigentlich ganz geil. Ja, daran merkt man langsam, dass Leute verrückt werden, wenn die überall so Türtöpfe stehen haben, wo sie immer einmal mal gucken, was passiert. Ich glaube eh, dass du deinen kompletten Müll einfach eingraben kannst und irgendwas wird wachsen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ist das nicht viel besser, seinen Müll zu vergraben im Garten einfach? Dann kommt so ein kleiner Stefan raus. Was hast du weggeworfen? Taschentüfe. So ein kleiner Nippon-Reis-Waffelnbaum. Also Nippon-What the? So Schoko-Waffeln wachsen einem Baum. Ja, wir finden dadurch raus, dass eine Süßigkeit gar keine Süßigkeit ist, die chemisch hergestellt wird, sondern natürlich wächst. Es sind einfach Früchte. Schoko-Fresh. Ja genau, Schoko-Fresh. Es sind einfach so komische Käfer aus dem Amazonas, die halt einfach so eine Milchfüllung haben. Wie, das sind tote Käfer? Da hast du so eine ganze Kolonie Mini-Schokofresh rumlaufen. Die werden erst ganz klein, dann werden sie grösser und dann sterben sie. Ich habe einfach noch keine Vorstellung von Erdnüssen. Der Name suggeriert ja, dass sie unter der Erde wachsen. Ja genau, aber die haben diese Schale auch und dann da drin ist halt dann die Nuss. Ja, diese Schale, wow. Danke für diesen Hinweis. Immer so Doppelnuss. Haben Sie Erdnuss studiert? Ja, klar. Ich bin Erdnussexperte. Danke, dass Sie endlich mal anrufen. Seit 16 Jahren sitze ich in diesem Büro. Das ist die Erdnuss-Komplettlösung-Hotline. Das Telefon ist still und kalt. Das erdnussförmige Telefon steht still. Einmal im Monat rufe ich beim Hausmeister an, ob mein Telefonanschluss funktioniert. Er macht einen Testanruf, kommt durch. Also daran liegt es nicht. War der Klingelton, Peanut Butter Jelly Time? Ja, tatsächlich lange Zeit schon. Ja, völlig richtig, der Erdnuss Hotline. Und ich habe mal angerufen bei so einer Birnenfirma und wollte wissen, warum deren Birnsorte so heißt,, wie sie heisst. Und da ist jemand rangegangen. Also ich habe dann wirklich mit jemandem geredet, der mir erklärt hat, wie diese Birnsorte funktioniert. Und wo ich mir auch denke, was macht der denn den Rest des Tages? Sitze da rum und warte, dass Leute Birnenfragen haben und da richtig viel zu tun. Die Antwort ist oft Privatleute, die denen, also ich habe auch, man hat mir so eine Wolldecke gekauft und auch da ist eine Handynummer drauf gewesen, also da ist sehr professionelles Etikett und da war es eine Handynummer geschrieben von so einer, wahrscheinlich eine Oma in Wales, die jetzt diese Decken näht und häkelt und was es strickt, was es auch noch für Begriffe gibt und die dann in die Welt verschickt und irgendwie einen Sohn hat, der geile Grafik machen kann. Man sieht schon sehr professionell aus, dieses Etikett. Und wahrscheinlich ist es einfach ihre Handnummer und dann hat man eine Frage zur Decke, eine Frage auch zur Decke. Und dann sagt ihr das. Entschuldigung, ich habe jetzt die Decke, aber nur über meinem Oberkörper. Aber das freut mich, gefällt Ihnen die Decke? Die Decke ist wunderschön, ja.
Das Problem ist, ich habe die Decke jetzt halt über meinen Oberkörper gelegt.
Ich höre sie nicht mehr.
Einen Moment.
Genau, ich habe die Decke über meinen Oberkörper gelegt.
Jetzt sind meine Füsse aber kalt.
Das ist ein ganz altbekanntes Problem.
Ja, das, okay.
Da müssten sie nur...
Hallo? Hallo nach Wales? Oh. This is Wales calling. This is never Wales calling. Who is Wales? Wales calling. Es fand ich echt schade, dass der Eurovision Song Contest ausgefallen ist. Ja, die ganzen Tweets. Ich twitter ja nicht mehr viel, aber die Eurovision Song Contest ist der eine Abend, wo ich immer noch gerne Twitter. Die ganzen süssen Tweets. Alle weg, alle im Abfluss. Ich finde es so schön, wenn alle gucken und alle gucken die gleiche Sendung, ganz Europa ja in diesem Fall sogar und Australien neuerdings. Und dann sitzt man dann da und kann zusammen das gucken und twittern darüber. Das finde ich immer toll. Das ist ein Event. Was ist das nächste große Event eigentlich? Turmspringen. Das war auch immer noch so Events, diese Raab-Sachen. Die sind jetzt alle kostenlos guckbar bei Maispaas. Wegen Corona haben die jetzt die ganzen Schl Schlag den Raab-Sendungen wieder online gestellt, die ich hier gerne geguckt habe damals. Total. Aber ich glaube, die sind nicht so gut gealtert, um ehrlich zu sein. Nee, nee, das ist, wie gesagt, das lebt ja von dem Live-Event. Aber ich habe echt Traumata, was MySpaas angeht. Weil irgendwie, ich habe auf MySpaas, glaube ich, Stromberg geguckt, alle Staffeln oder so. Und ich weiß nicht warum, aber zu der Zeit, als ich das geguckt habe, hatten die immer so Werbeunterbrechungen und haben dann so Werbeclips gespielt, aber anscheinend hatten die zu wenig Werbepartner, sodass immer der exakt selbe Spot lief, teilweise drei, vier Mal hintereinander und ich bin völlig wahnsinnig geworden, einfach immer dieselbe Werbung. Ich bin ja nie so sehr über neue Spots gefreut wie bei MySpa. So endlich ein neuer.
Nicht Nivea, nicht Nivea, nicht Nivea, nicht Nivea.
Check24, yes!
Wirklich endlich mal was, was ich nicht mitsprechen darf. Das ist ein bisschen wie, ich weiß nicht, ob du auf Twitch aktiv bist, aber da ist es ja so, dass Twitch und Amazon zusammengehören. Das heißt, die machen hauptsächlich Werbung für Amazon-Serien und es ist immer dasselbe. Es ist immer diese scheiß Purge, es ist immer Vikings, es ist immer dann diese Superhelden-Dinger, immer dasselbe und es ist unfassbar nervig. Ich kann jedem mitreden mittlerweile. Es ist einfach furchtbar. Ja, das nervt, das glaube ich auch. Also die Antwort wäre ja, mehr Werbepartner zu finden. Wir sollten wie immer Werbung machen bei Twitch. Ja, oder kann man nicht auch Werbung machen für Leute, die das gar nicht wollen? Ist das verboten? Also könnten wir jetzt Werbung machen für eine Firma, ohne dass sie das will?
Ich will nicht zu viel Einblick in die Interna geben, aber es ist schon vorgekommen, dass wir ungefragt Werbung gemacht haben. Wir haben mit diesem Podcast schon Werbung gemacht, darf man nicht sagen, darf man auch nicht zu laut sagen, aber ohne Geld dafür zu bekommen. Er dreht mal runter jetzt die Lautstärke. Einfach weil ich aber auch diese Excel, ich habe keine Erfahrung mehr mit Excel-Tabellen, ich kann die nicht mehr so richtig lesen. Und dann rutscht man plötzlich nach rechts mit dem Daumen und sieht man, ah, da ist eine ganz neue Spalte, die ich noch nie gesehen habe. Ja. Und es ist auch ein Fehler, weil die immer in KWs, Kalenderwochen, wer zählt in Kalenderwochen? Wer auch immer Kalenderwochen erfunden hat, wirklich. Gehört gestrafen. Es gibt Daten. Ja, es gibt Daten. Warum sollte man eine neue Einheit erfinden? Aber es ist ja auch so ein bisschen wie, man darf nicht stehlen, aber darf man Sachen in den Supermarkt bringen? Also darf ich jetzt eine Packung Nudeln im Supermarkt ins Regal legen? So Anti-Diebstahl? Das ist mir jetzt passiert. Ich habe nämlich ein paar Sachen bestellt für meine neue Wohnung und eine Freundin hat auch neue Sachen bestellt für die neue Wohnung. Und jetzt habe ich, wie es der Zufall so wollte, Dinge von ihr auch zurückgeschickt und ich habe noch nie so eine verwirrte Mail bekommen von diesem Versandhaus,, der gesagt hat, was ist das für ein Blumentopf?
Und ich so, nee, wie...
Also kein sehr geehrter Hettize,
kein... Nein, einfach nur ein...
Einfach nur in Capital Letters
Was zur Hölle
ist das für ein Blumentopf?
Und ich habe gesagt, Moment mal kurz, erst mal, hallo,
vor mir, sie kennenzulernen,
gibt es Probleme mit meiner Retour?
Und dann direkt wieder, haben wir ihnen falsche Sachen geschickt oder was ist das hier?
Und dann habe ich denen einfach einen Blumentopf zurückgeschickt, den ich gar nicht bestellt habe. Und seitdem sehe ich die Welt brennen in einem sehr lustigen E-Mail-Verlauf, wo ich nicht genau weiss, wie der ausgeht. Ja, es stimmt schon, aber es gab mal jemanden, der so, ich weiss nicht, wer das war, irgendeinen Musiker, glaube ich, der so beim Mediamarkt seine CDs in die Regale getan hat, aber halt nicht verkauft, sondern der hat die da einfach reingestellt, in der Hoffnung, dass Leute seine Musik hören. Ja. Und dann war die Frage, darf man das oder nicht, wer verbietet einem das? Aber ich glaube, er muss sie richtig sortiert haben, also er muss, wenn dann auch beim richtigen Buchstaben einsortieren. Ja, das auf jeden Fall schon. Das ist Strafe. Was ist mit der Todesstrafe? Das ist Todesstrafe. Dass man Sachen umräumt. Wir machen so eine Packung Schokofresh. Einfach ins Kürigal legen. Ja, ich glaube, es ist so, wir nerven halt so. Nee, Wettbewerbsverzerrung. Das ist Wettbewerbsverzerrung. Wenn ich jetzt beim Lidl Schokofresh kaufe und die in meinen Rewe packe, dann hat doch der Rewe einen Vorteil. Ja. Wobei, nee, ich bin der einzige Gelackmeierte, weil ich zahle jetzt, ich zahle ja drauf, ich zahle ja, Lidl kriegt ja Geld für die Schokofresh und Rewe wird doppelt bezahlen. Aber ich glaube, du könntest beide, also du könntest einen verwirren, wenn du Waren in den Laden stellst, die dann verkauft werden und dann die mehr verkaufen, als sie haben oder Produkte verkaufen, die sie gar nicht verkaufen. Das ist es nämlich. Das ist es nämlich. Produkte verkaufen, die sie gar nicht haben. Das ist ja bei diesem Versand, das ist auch passiert. Und die haben gesagt, das haben wir gar nicht im Sortiment. Jetzt haben sie diesen Blumentopf. Und ich bin mit meiner, ich weiß nicht, wovon Sie sprechen, No hablo aleman-Taktik nicht so gut gefangen dann, wenn dann kommt. Ja, jetzt kriege ich auch kein Geld zurück. Es ist halt einfach ein Blumentopf, woanders, wo er nicht hingehört. Jetzt bin ich auch kurz davor, in so eine Glitch City zu kommen, glaube ich.
Ja, vor allem mittlerweile, glaube ich, ist der beste Weg, sowas rauszufinden. Hör mal seinen Podcast. Hör mal seinen Podcast, der erzählt bestimmt davon und dann hört er von der Mail und dann weiss er, wie es auch geklärt ist. Ohne Scheiss, wirklich, ich frage mich, wann zum ersten Mal dieser Podcast vor Gericht als Beweismittel zugleich. Ah, das wär das Schönste.
Ich hab übrigens eine ganz tolle Anleitung bekommen von jemandem, wie man ...
Weil ich hab halt letzte Woche vorgeschlagen ... Podcast vor Gericht als Beweismittel zugleich. Das wäre das Schönste. Ich habe übrigens eine ganz tolle Anleitung bekommen
von jemandem, wie man
weil ich habe letzte Woche vorgeschlagen,
als Freizeitbeschäftigung zum
Gericht mal zu gehen. Ja! Und ich habe eine
ganz tolle Nachricht bekommen
von Robin, der mir
geschrieben hat, wie man das angehen soll. Eine Anleitung,
eine kleine. Und zwar, also sowas
wie, wenn du in den Freizeitpark willst, komm morgen früh hin, weil dann bist du der Erste und kannst Achterbahn fahren. Ah ja, okay, also so Insider-Infos. Insider-Infos, wie man es am besten macht. Hi Stefan, habe im Podcast zu hören, du planst eine, na ja, gut. Da dies auch eines meiner Hobbys ist, wollte ich dir kurz einfach nur vier Tipps da lassen. Erstens gehe nicht zum Amtsgericht. Am Amtsgericht werden nur die kleinen Fische abverhandelt. Person X hat zur Person Y Beleidigung gesagt, jemand ist schwarz gefahren etc. Dies ist in der Regel maximal unspektakulär. Moment, wenn ich kurz einhaken darf. Ist das nicht viel interessanter, Person X, Y hat mich beleidigt, hat mich als Miese Rübe bezeichnet. Ja, aber entschuldigen Sie, Miese Rübe ist doch keine Beleidigung. Natürlich ist Miese Rübe nicht... Das sind doch die Diskussionen, die ich hören will. Ich bin schwarz gefahren, nein, sind Sie nicht, doch... Doch, nö. Nö. Doch, sind Sie. Nö. Nein. Warum hatten Sie denn keine Fahrkarte dabei? Ich hatte eine Fahrkarte dabei. Dann nimmt er so eine Knarre raus und schießt auf den Richter oder sowas. Sie miese Rübe, so, nächster Raum, nächster Raum. Dies ist in der Regel maximal unspektakulär, gehe stattdessen zum Landgericht und achte in der Terminübersicht auf die Verhandlungssache. Zweitens, die Verhandlungssache. In den Terminen steht auch kurz, um was es geht. Eröffnungsverfahren, Schlichtungsverfahren, Strafverfahren, eventuell sogar für das Schöpfunggericht. Achte auf diese Keywords. Was vor einer grossen erweiterten Strafkammer verhandelt wird, ist auch ein grösseres Verbrechen, gleich mehr Fun in der Regel. Drittens, Terminart. Achte auf die Terminart. Das hat die Überschriftung gesagt. Erste Termine sind gerade bei grösseren Verfahren in der Regel nicht so spannend. Die Anklage wird verlesen, die Anwälte stellen Verfahrensanträge, alles ziemlich trockene Jura. Termine zur Beweisaufnahme sind da eventuell schon spannender. Hier können Zeugen befragt werden, Indizien bewertet werden und natürlich Termine zur Urteilsverkündung sind spannend, gerade wenn man den Fall schon mehrere Tage lang verfolgt. Wow, du hast wirklich, was machst du beruflich? Vielleicht hilft das mega, vielen, vielen Dank, finde ich ganz, ganz toll. Das ist wirklich eine ganz tolle Anleitung und sehr anschaulich. So kann ich meinen ersten Gerichtsbesuch in meinem Rechtes-Geil-Outfit, glaube ich, ganz gut frönen. Ja, macht das und zieht auf jeden Fall euer Podcast UFO Merch an. Vielleicht findet ihr ja Gleichgesinnte im Gerichtssaal und dann gibt es grosse Versöhnungs-Stories, während da irgendjemand zusammenbricht, weil er gerade eine Gefängnisstrafe bekommt. Bist du auch zum ersten Mal hier? Ja. Wow, ich sehe auch da so ein Podcast-Ufo-Shirt an. Ja, vermisst du auch Antenne Afrika? Ja, nein, nein, manchmal, manchmal. Ruhe bitte da hinten, ihr beiden, auseinander. Ja, Die beiden mit dem komischen Merch von Steve Harrington. Die beiden Steve-Harring-Fans, bitte auseinander. Na, das ist Podcast, Ruhe! Ich habe Steve Harrington gesagt, was der Charakter von Stranger Things ist. Was in etwa alles über mich und mein Kunstverständnis aussagt. Naja. Oder gerade, naja. Ist okay. Vielen Dank für die ganz vielen tollen Nachrichten. Vielen, vielen Dank. Wir haben auch ein... Aber vor allem für die tollen Zeichnungen. Ja, ganz kurz noch einen Zwischenschub, weil wir gerade beim Thema Straffälligkeit und Verantwortung, Rache, Vergeltung, Sühne und Gerechtigkeit sind. Mich hat eine Mail erhalten von Luisa. Kurze Erinnerung, Luisa ist die Kaninchen-Schlechterin von Köln, die ein harmloses, wehrloses Kaninchen überfahren und damit zu Tode gedrückt hat. So lange draufgedrückt mit ihrem Eintonnen-Polo, bis das Kaninchen sich verabschiedet hat.
Auf eine Tonne muss man sagen. So ein Corsa auch.
Ja, so lange auf, mit einer Tonne Gewicht draufgedrückt, bis das Kaninchen gesagt hat, Leute, ich pack's, ich bin raus und es ist nicht mehr aufgestanden nach ihrer. Ja, sie hat nochmal eine Mail geschrieben und um, ja, Entschuldigung gewinselt, sie meinte, seitdem fährt sie nur noch Fahrrad, ist also mit dem Fahrrad auf Könnchenjagd und versucht dann mit ihren wie viel Kilo auch immer, Könnchen zu Tode zu drücken und haltet euch auf jeden Fall vor Luisa fern. Ja, wir haben jetzt mit dem Rad gegen Fernhalten. Sie ist weiterhin auf freiem Fuss und ich glaube, da wird uns noch ein weiteres Verbrechen demnächst bevorstehen. Okay. Wir haben ganz viele tolle Zeichnungen bekommen. Wir haben wirklich ganz viele tolle Zeichnungen bekommen. Zum Thema Hüsterich und Schnieferinchen ist eingeschlagen, wie Kinderbücher einschlagen in der Podcastszene. Es war ein Riesenthema und es wurde eine Menge dazu geschrieben und wir haben einige Illustrationen bekommen. Ich glaube, die fassen wir alle auf der Puffopedia zusammen. Ihr könnt ja mal vorbeigucken auf unserem Hüsterich und Schnieferinchen, unserem Kinderbuchprojekt, das schon einiges an Anklang gefunden hat. Auf jeden Fall. Ich fände es ganz tolle Zeichnungen. Es gab auch übrigens von Kaninchen Zeichnungen, die sie vermischt haben mit Hüsterich und Schnieferinchen, wo ich kurz dachte, ich bin so ein Fiebertraum. Ist so ein bisschen, ein Podcast zu moderieren ist manchmal so, also vor allem die Twitter-Timeline ist dann ein grosser Fiebertraum, aus dem man aber nicht aufwachen kann, weil es die Wahrheit ist. Teilen aus von vor Monaten und von vor Jahren. Vor allem, warst du in einem Fiebertraum oder in einem Fieberotraum? Fieberot, Fieberot, Fieberot, hallo Hysterich. Haha, Fibaro ist das Fie-Thermometer. Und was sie auch noch, mir eine Mutter geschrieben hat, kleiner Shoutout an Mütter an der Stelle, eine Mutter hat geschrieben, dass ihr Sohn sich keine warmen Sachen anziehen wollte, um rauszugehen, und ihre Mutter hat damit gedroht, dass wenn er seine Sachen nicht anzieht, dann kommt Schnieferinchen vorbei. Und dann hat er es recht alles ausgezogen, weil wie cool ist es denn, wenn Schnieferinchen vorbeikommt. Aber Schnieferinchen ist mittlerweile schon so eine Drohfigur, so der Krampus oder der Teufel oder so. Und er sagt einfach, wenn du das nicht machst, kommt Schnieferinchen. Nein, ich will nicht, ich mache alles. Also ich finde das perfekt, süstes Kinderbuch, aber auch Erpressung. Ja, wie der Strubbelpeter ja letztlich. Ja, im Grund schon. Grauenhaft, der hat mich auch richtig verstört. Ich denke immer noch, ich glaube, ich schneide auch meine Nägel zu kurz. Wirklich, wegen fucking Strouvelpeter. Ja, peter. Furchtbar, und Zappelphilip und dann dieser, der seine Suppe nicht leer löffelt und so. Ja, ja, der Suppenkasper. Wahnsinn. Der ganz dünn wie Dürr wird. Terror. Und nun stirbt. Einfach so dieses pädagogische Konzept, einfach den Kindern so viel Angst zu machen, wie es geht. Ja, und das war ja auch ewig okay, auch dieser Scherenmann, der den Daumen abgeschnitten hat vom Daumenlutscher. Wobei, das habe ich letztendlich zu lange gemacht, Daumenlutschen. Er hat es nicht gebraucht. Aber es ist schon ganz geil, oder? Daumenlutschen, mega. Also wirklich schon. Es ist so wie wir rauchen eigentlich, für die Kinder. Es ist eine Art Rauchen, ja. Man darf es nicht, aber man steht cool an der Ecke. Oh, es ist das gleiche, es ist ein orales Verlangen. Ja, und im Grunde, ich meine, oh, kann man vielleicht sagen, die, die daumen lutschen, fangen auch eher an zu rauchen. Oder andersrum, die, die nicht daumen lutschen dürfen, fangen dann eher an zu rauchen. Ja. Wo ist die Wissenschaft? Ja. Hallo? Auch gut, dass man immer in beide Richtungen argumentieren kann. Ja. Drosti. Wo ist Drosti unterwegs? Drosti. Kellogs Drostis. Kleine Coronaviren kannst du essen, die haben auch diese rote Farbe und innen sind sie so grün. Ja, und in jeder Packung gibt es irgendwie so einen schönen Handschuh oder so. Kleinen Handschuhen, Mundschutz, Kellogs, Rossis.
Finde ich so schlecht. und in jeder Packung gibt es irgendwie so einen schönen Handschuh oder sowas. Kleinen Handschuh, Mundschutz. Kellogg's Trostys.
Finde ich so schlecht. Andere Cornflakes.
Andere Wissenschaftler.
Top fünf Virologen. Top fünf
wissenschaftliche Cornflakes-Sorten.
Kann man
Kellogg's Trostys noch sagen?
Nein. nein?
Putin ist off. Kekulé kenne ich noch. Boah. Du wolltest unbedingt zum High-Open-Mic gehen.
Ich hasse auch nicht. Du wolltest unbedingt zum Open Mic gehen.
Und jetzt sitzen wir hier und schwarten Stille.
Ich hasse Open Mic.
Also auf Platz Nummer fünf der wissenschaftlichen Cornflakes. Ja.
Wow.
Oh, da haben wir gerade einen Fehler mit dem Projekt gehabt.
Da ist gerade irgendwie das Projekt hat sich abgebrochen die letzten zehn Minuten.
Die waren so lustig, sind jetzt einfach weg, verschwunden irgendwie.
Wir hatten so tolle Ideen, wir hatten verschiedene Konflikte. Wir hatten zum Beispiel. Oh, irgendwie ist heute Wurm drin, jetzt war gerade nochmal ein Aussetzer, ganz komisch. Naja, musst du dringend den Griff bekommen mit deinem Laptop, das Problem. Wo waren wir? Weltraum. Wir wurden gerade bei den Kellogg's Drost die Alternative. Halt die Fresse, halt die Klappe. Also ich glaube, glaubst du nicht, dass das Virologen in der Zukunft ein sehr hart umkämpfter Berufszweig wird, dass die Kinder von heute wollen Virologen werden, nicht mehr Astronauten? Genau, weil nach dem Krieg wollten ja auch alle Soldaten werden. Naja, ich meine, Astronauten sind
mittlerweile offiziell uncool, die nur noch
auf so ein Touchpad gucken und aussehen wie irgendwie
so eine Zahnpassage. Was hast du mit deinem Aversion gegen Touchpad?
Das ist doch mega. Ja, aber ich weiß nicht,
das ist so, jedes vierjährige Kind sitzt
vor einem Touchscreen. Und dann die Astronauten
auch. Ich habe jetzt, ich habe auch die Schnauze vor
von Touchpads. Jetzt habe ich, ähm, bei meiner
neuen Küche war so ein Backofen dabei.
Habe mich nicht vorher damit beschäftigt, was das für einer ist. Jetzt ist es so ein super krasser, den ich nicht brauche, wo du kannst die Tür nicht mehr aufmachen, du musst so einen Knopf drücken, dass die Tür aufgeht, dann geht die automatisch auf und so ein Dreck. Dann hast du so automatische Programme, du kannst deine Fleischart eingeben, du kannst wirklich eingeben Dry-Aged T-Bone Steak und kannst dann so einen Schieberegler einstellen von English bis Well Done. Ja, völlig übertrieben, völlig übertrieben. Und es ist wirklich schwieriger, einfach den einzustellen auf 160 Grad. Das war nicht anstrengend. Mit Spracherkennung? Ja, wahrscheinlich. Quiche. Quiche Lorraine. Quiche. Sie sagten Kirschkuchen. Quiche. Du kannst sogar eingehen, was für ein Brot du willst und wie hell und dunkel es sein soll verstehe ich alles nicht so richtig und du einfach schön deine Salami-TKP reinpfeffer und einfach noch ein bisschen oder mein Öl und Käse drauf oder mein Knoblauchbrot reinmache und einfach, ich bin doch nur auf 120 Ich will, dass es in der Mitte noch gefroren ist, bitte. Sie sagten Kirschkuchen. Nein! Oder einfach, Sie haben keinen Geschmack. Lassen Sie sich helfen. Ich mag es, wenn es so ein bisschen undurch ist. Ich mag es, wenn es noch eiskalt in der Mitte ist. Nein, mögen Sie nicht. Ja, es ist eine schwierige Zeit. Ich habe jetzt auch tatsächlich meinen Sandwich-Toaster geholt.
Oh, ist es soweit?
Es ist soweit, habe ein bisschen experimentiert, es klappt tatsächlich
mit dem Backpapier. Ich war skeptisch
wegen den Dimensionen. Ich dachte ja,
Backpapier ist zweidimensional,
Sandwich-Toaster ist dreidimensional, gibt es da nicht
so eine Art Dimensionsriss irgendwie, muss man
nicht durch erst die vierte Dimension so umklappen,
um da hinzukommen. Aber es klappt.
Ja, es klappt meistens. Das ist merkwürdig, aber es klappt. Ich habe auch heute überlegt, was passiert, wenn ich die Pizza reinmache, aber auf Flammkuchen klicke. Kommt ein Flammkuchen raus, oder was? Weiß ich nicht. Was passiert dann? Weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Ohne Scheiss. Oder mal so ein Roggenbrot und ich klicke aber auf Sauerteig. Was ist, wenn ich Waffelteig in den Sandwichmaker tue? Habe ich denn eine Sandwichwaffel? Waffel, Swaffle. Das ist ja eine geniale Idee. Was ist, wenn ich eine Tiefkühlpizza in Sandwich Maker tue? Und dann auf Flammkuchen kleben. Und dann auf Quiche, dann Quichebrülle, während es backt, bugt, bagt. Backte, dann kommen, glaube ich, deine Nachbarn und sagen, so, Herr Will, das war es jetzt für Sie, kommen Sie bitte mit. So, Sie sind verhaftet. Kleines Update, vielleicht nochmal für dich an der Stelle zum Thema Vokabel-App. Es sind ja tatsächlich mittlerweile Leute aus der Community dran an dieser Vokabel-App. Wirklich jetzt? Ja, die tatsächlich programmieren. Ich habe noch ein neues Feature mir überlegt, und zwar ist es ja oft so, wenn man Sprache lernt, dann liest man ... Jetzt sagst du die Dinge mittlerweile auch, einfach weil ihr den Vorsprung habt, denkst du, den Programmiervorsprung. Ja, natürlich, auf jeden Fall. Das kann jetzt niemand mehr einholen. Wir haben schon ein paar Bütze bei uns zusammengeschaufelt, da ist schon, da entsteht schon was. Sehr hässlich, sehr hässliche App. Okay, du wolltest... Tatsächlich, meine Idee ist, je hässlicher Apps sind, desto funktionaler sind sie. Meine Erfahrung, wenn die so hochglanz, super mit wabernden Grafiken und so, unbrauchbar. Exakt das Gegenteil. Die müssen so grottenhstig sein. Deswegen ist deine Wohnung so funktional und meine so schön, aber funktioniert nicht. Beide kannst du nicht leben. Ja, gut. Deine Tür ist zu klein, du musst dich ducken, wenn du durch die Tür gehst. Und zwar dachte ich, wenn man ein Vokabel nachschlägt, oft ist es ja so, du liestest einen Text und verstehst kein einziges Wort und schlägst jeder einzelne Vokabel nach. Und wenn du die Vokabel nachgeschlagen hast, ist da ein kleiner Button dabei, als Karteikarte zu dem Stapel hinzufügen. Genial! Wait, wait, wait, du musst acht Schritte zurückgehen. Du schaust eine Vokabel nach, du liest Goeffel und guckst dann nach im French Vokabelheft, was heißt Goeffel, Le Goeffel und dann klickst du daneben auf die Feder und dann wird es automatisch als Karteikarte bei dir im Karteistabe gespeichert. Wie genial ist das denn? Auf die dunkle Feder, weil die andere Feder heisst Notiz machen. Ja, das ist ein bisschen viele Feature. Wie heisst die App? Faeser. Ist sie denn nur für Französisch oder für alle Sprachen? Für alle Sprachen der Welt, wenn wir tatsächlich die Rechte kriegen. Wir sind da noch dran, wir sind noch am niederländischen Konsulat, die sagen no, no, no way, ihr kriegt unsere Sprache nicht, ihr Schweine, aber da sind wir gerade noch in der Verhandlung, aber wenn wir alle Lizenzen haben, dann haben wir alle Sprachen der Welt und dann hast du neben jedem Wort sind 17 Federn und eins heißt aussprechen lassen, eins zeigt mir einen Film, in dem dieses Wort eine große Rolle spielt, zeigt mir einen Zaubertrick, um ein bisschen Abwechslung reinzubringen, irgendwie ins Vokabeln. Film glaube ich, nicht, dass es funktioniert, da müsst ihr ja die Rechte an den Film haben. Ja, aber auch da sind wir in Verhandlungen mit Warner Brothers, die klammern sich sehr an ihre Lizenzen. Es wäre lustig, wenn ihr einen Film bekommt, aber der deckt grob die meisten Wörter ab. Und dann können sich irgendwann die Welt zusammen über Sex and City City 2 unterhalten, einfach weil alle da lernen mit. Und das ist die perfekte App, um Sex in the City 2 zu lernen, aber für alles andere einfach unbrauchbar. Aber das wird bald auch auf den Markt kommen, also abonniert schon mal Vesa, vielleicht heißt die App so, vielleicht auch anders, mal gucken. Ist it a worst bird production eigentlich? It is a worst bird production, google da einfach mal, ansonsten, wie gesagt, haben wir auch mit Weser noch...
Wir brauchen demnächst auf jeden Fall unsere Website, die muss mal langsam ein bisschen auf Vordermann gebracht werden, die Worst Bird Seite.
Ja.
Bei Worst Bird Productions, ich finde, wir brauchen so eine Portfolio-Seite, so eine Über uns, wo einfach Bund-Projekte, Kinderbuch, aber es muss wahnsinnig toll aussehen, diese Seite.
Schokoriegel, ein spanischer Schokoriegel, ja, El Chocolat. Dann diese Französisch-Lern-App, Feser. Spanischer Schokoriegel 2020 bis 2021, einfach so sofort wieder abgesagt. Nur wieder Lebenslauf, man merkt, der hat sich nicht entschieden. Ja. Auch so ein Work and Travel für drei Jahre. Eine portugiesische Soap oder sowas, auch lief für 24 Minuten. Hat aber drei Milliarden Euro gemacht. Drei Millionen pesos, drei Millionen portugiesische pesos dafür eingenommen. Dann können wir mal dazuschreiben, wie viel Geld wir eingenommen haben. Das würde mich auch interessieren. Steht dann bei so Leuten so Sachen, aber da steht nicht drin, wie viel haben sie dafür bekommen. Ich bin dafür, wir machen die Seite neu. Und ich wünsche dir sehr viel Erfolg mit deiner französischen Lern-App. Dankeschön, mit unserer französischen Lern-App. Wie gesagt, ich habe da auch Finanzen der, ich habe die da die Worst-Bird-Kasse geplündert, um da schon so ein paar Programmierer zu bezahlen, die sehr teuer sind, extrem teuer. Ja, Programmierer sind teuer, die lassen sich das ordentlich bezahlen. Die lassen sich richtig vergolden, die sagen so, ich schreibe hier keine Zeit, Code ohne Moneten. Ohne Monetas, oder das französische Wort für Moneten? Le Monet, Le Gemont, Jean-Morland, Jean-Morland, Jean-Morland, Jean-Morland, Jean-Morland. Im Slang bin ich noch nicht drin, Argent glaube ich, aber im Slang bin ich noch nicht drin. Also was so, Zaster, Kneten. Argent. Zaster? Argent, ich glaube schon. Bugs? Ten Bugs. Bugs, vor allem man lernt so die ersten zehn Vokabeln in der neuen Sprache, ist Zaster, Knete, Moneten. Bugs, einfach so die verschiedenen Slangwörter für Geld, das ist das erste, was man lernt. Die ersten zwanzig Wörter.
Argent ist Geld?
Ich glaube ja.
Das klingt fantastisch.
Ich sag das jetzt mal so.
Das sag ich schon so gern, das Wort jetzt. Argent.
Kannst du schon mal sagen, wenn du in Frankreich bist?
Wie schreibt man das?
Argent, glaube ich.
Du meinst mich hier in eine Sackgasse, aus der ich nicht mehr rauskomme.
Okay, deklinier mal Argent. Je Argent? Nein, nein, du konjugierst es. Ja, wie? Naja, Geldes, Genitiv zum Beispiel. Ja, Stefan, ich wünsche dir ganz, ganz viel Erfolg mit deinem Küchenprojekt. Das wäre mir jetzt auch toll, wenn du auf die Fehler klickst, auf die andere Fehler klickst. Auf das Thema wird gewechselt? Nee, dass du dann alle Fälle hast, einmal durchdekliniert wird. Ja, aber die Fälle gibt es so im Französischen glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube aber doch. Geldes und gelden. In jedem Fall haben die Fälle, ist Französisch. Vielleicht auch nicht. Naja. Geschlechte. Ja, ja. Ja, ja. Ich überhaupt nicht an, wie gesagt, ich sitze im Worst Bird Turm. Du, du sitzt in der Zentrale und im Worst Bird Horst sitze ich im Nest und würde einfach warten darauf. nest at worstbird.de Ja, das ist unsere E-Mail-Resse, nest at worstbird.com Würmer, Würmer in den Hals at worst at worstbird.com Best at worstbird aber das ist wie so ein Kult, wo jeder so einen Namen hat. Die Praktikanten heißen kleiner Vogel oder so oder Fliegling. Wie heißt ein junger Vogel? Küken. Küken, ja genau, die Praktikanten sind Küken, Küken, Küken, Küken, Küken, Küken und dann geht es immer so hoch und der Chef ist irgendwie Papa Bear oder sowas. Ja, haut rein, ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche. Greisvogel vielleicht, die älteren. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Ja, alles Gute, ich wünsche euch eine fantastische Woche. Schaut in den Himmel oder auf den Boden. Jedenfalls habe ich jetzt eine tolle App gefunden, die heißt If This Then That, damit kann man tolle Wenn Dann Ketten auf seinem Handy programmieren. Ich kriege jetzt immer eine Push-Mitteilung, wenn die ISS über meine Wohnung fliegt. Super nervig, weil die andauernd immer wenn eine Wohnung fliegt, aber trotzdem spannend. Und wenn es dunkel ist und sie fliegt über einen, direkt sieht man es auch nicht. Aber gut, anderes Thema, Lichtverschmutzung. Reden wir nächste Woche drüber. Alles klar, freut mich auf nächste Woche, wir reden nun mal nicht vor Schmutzung, wir haben vielleicht einen Experten an der Hand, auch nicht. Aber gut, anderes Thema, Lichtverschmutzung, reden wir nächste Woche drüber. Alles klar, freut mich auf nächste Woche, wir reden über Lichtverschmutzung, wir haben vielleicht einen Experten an der Hand, vielleicht nicht, mal gucken.
Macht's gut, macht's gut, tschau.
Schöne Woche, tschau, tschau.
It's a Wallsberg production.